>>Daniel: Thank you all for coming. I'm glad
to be here with you, and I'll launch right
into this and to tell you that the reason
we began with this clip, aside from giving
you a sense of what the film was like, is
because it contains, or it contains three
different kinds of truths that are important.
The first is the truth about what happens
to, when people try to disseminate knowledge
and galvanize people to do something about
this problem, which is that there's a lot
of push back.
That's what I received for it when it was
Executioners, that's what anyone receives
who wants to stand up and say, "The killing
must stop. We have to do something." Particularly
when you say what we have to do is something
forceful. There's enormous push back because
people don't want to do anything. Not everybody,
but many, including many powerful people.
A second truth that you saw in this film is
in the person of Ellie Nicarambe, so it's
a small-scale truth. And it's the truth of
the perpetration on the ground of these kinds
of deeds or crimes, which is that at every
moment or a moment after moment, one person
decides to raise his hand, looking at a victim;
it can be a man, it can be a woman, it can
be a child, and he decides, or she, they're
usually men, but there are some women, decide
to strike the victim and to kill the person.
Overwhelmingly, victims of genocide, of mass
murder, in our time, have been felled in a
personalistic way with the killer facing the
victim, often bludgeoning the victim or cutting
the victim with, n-, with pre-20th century
weaponry. That's why we have to keep this
in mind. The small-scale truth about the reality
of what happens.
And then, there's a large-scale truth that
you saw, which is the enormity of the problem.
Genocide has taken more victims than conventional
military operations during our time. Indeed,
many, many more -- it's not even close. This
fact should be known to every concerned citizen
of our country and indeed of all countries.
And it is a fact, which is unknown to virtually
every single citizen of our country and the
rest of the world.
And when you hear this, it changes the way
you see the world. War, which is at the center
of international security concerns and policy-making
and at the center of the concerns of international
political institutions, should be side by
side with the prevention or stopping of genocide.
Which, right now, is treated as a secondary
or tertiary phenomenon, certainly not central
to international security discussions or policy-making.
So, this large-scale fact should change how
you understand the world and what is a, the
chief problem of lethal violence in the world
today -- it's mass murder. Now to talk about
this, as you have probably gleaned, my manner
is to be, to, just to be forceful. I don't
sugarcoat things. It's a very serious subject
I need hardly say, but I can't in this af-,
in this afternoon tell you everything that
you need to know that needs to be reconceptualized
or explicated.
If this were to be a full presentation, I
would go over how genocides begin -- why they
actually begin. Why they unfold in the ways
they do, why the perpetrators kill. What the
perpetrators' communities are like.
They're not atomized people. They live in
communities while they're killing and in larger
communities they are embedded, so what those
communities are like. How genocides end? A
critical topic, virtually unexplored. Why
different genocides issue in different outcomes.
Sometimes, mainly men are killed, sometimes
men, women and children. The numbers vary
enormously. Lots of things vary. Why do they
vary? And ultimately what we can do about
it. Full treatment of genocide would deal
with all these subjects.
I will touch on some of them, but not all
of them and if you have questions about the
others, I'll be happy to hear them or your
comments, for that matter. Now the truth,
and I will sit here and I will stand here
today and I will tell you what I think are
truths about genocide -- things that are undeniably
true. And that that often are, though they
are often contested or, or denied. It is not,
we must tell the truth about genocide.
The most fundamental truth is it's not, it
is not something that is overwhelming, not
beyond our understanding or beyond our control.
This is how it's often portrayed in the media
and in conversation. These eruptions occur,
what can you do? These people just kill each
other, what can you do? It's inevitable. It
will be with us for all of, for all time.
It's endemic to the human condition and so
on. These are the things that you hear or
the subtext of what is said about it. It's
simply not true. None of that is true.
[audience member clears throat]
It is as understandable as anything else.
It is within our control to do something about
it. We need political design, political will,
political ingenuity to do it. In fact, we
understand quite well why these things happen
and, I think, what we can do about them.
We need to tell the truth about the extent
of the problem. It's not just the numbers
that I've told you. We have to recognize that
this is a systemic feature of the modern world.
As bad as you think the Rwanda or the former
Yugoslavia or the Holocaust or Darfur or name
whatever genocide that you want. As bad as
you think that that is, these are typically
portrayed as a series of w-, unrelated one-off
events when, in fact, they are systemic features
of the internation-or-of the international
community or of the world order. Systematically
produced, we need to begin to see them that
way.
And the reason it's important is if you see
it as a systemic problem, than you begin to
think about systemic solutions and not just
waiting till the next one happens and say,
"What can we do here? What should we do? What
ought we do?" And either do it or more likely
not.
And, as I said, it must become a central feature
because it's systemic to world. The extent
of the problem is so great of international
security policy making. We must tell the truth
about the nature of the problem. The problem,
as bad as it is, is namely genocide, is not
even the real problem. It's not the most fundamental
problem. Genocide is but one manifestation
of, of more fundamental kind of politics,
which can be called eliminationism.
Eliminationism takes many forms, and it is
what it sounds like. It's a politics in which
states and the people supporting them, it's
almost always states, decide to eliminate
a group of people. That's the politics. The
reasons it is done vary from case to case.
It's something we could talk about. I'm not
going to get into now.
When they decide to eliminate a group, they
then choose a variety of eliminations means,
or eliminations tools to employ. And they
include force transformation, so forcing people
to convert from their religion, for example,
force transformation, incarceration in camps,
the prevention of a group's reproduction,
which is often done through sexual violence
-- rape. Expelling people and slaughtering
them, en mass, the largest such slaughters
of what we typically call genocide.
Now, the reason to look at the problem of
the politics of eliminationism as a federal
problem and not genocide, itself, is not just
because that really is what's going on. States
decide to do this, their followers say, "Oh,
yes, we have to get rid of these people,"
and then they carry it out. But also because
in every case of what we call genocide, the
perpetrators have used some of these, if not
all, these other eliminationist means at the
same time. And when you see that, you see
that genocide really is but a policy tool.
Or mass murder is a policy tool that goes
along with these other ones. So, we have to
start focusing on not just stopping the killing,
but on all forms of elimination politics and
come up with an anti-eliminationist political
response.
We need to tell the truth about the perpetrators.
They're not abstractions, they're not blindly
obedient as is often said to authority, they're
not just pressured to do what they do because
of the system, they're not bureaucrats as
they're often, as they have often been portrayed
-- just doing what bureaucrats do, which
is supposedly a job well done.
They are, as I told you earlier, they're individual
human beings working to get, working together,
but each one deciding what to do to raise
his hand, making decisions about what's right
and wrong -- knowing, having views about what's
right or wrong, and wrong. One thing that's
not in the film, I don't if, how many of you
have seen the film or if you're going to,
but one thing that is not in the film is in
Rwanda, we went to the war camp of the people
you saw in the opening clip. And it was early
afternoon, they'd finished their day of work,
they were having lunch and their lunch was
in a large shed. It was about 50 yards or
60 yards by 30 yards and there were benches,
so it's a rather big, a rather big place.
And their bench is in a parabolic form.
Actually, not very different from here. And,
and I went in there with the director of photography,
and I was standing not very different from
where I'm standing now at the point, at the
focal point of the parabola, and there were
no guards in this camp. It was a minimum-security
c-, camp, I will get, I can tell you later
why, and I looked out on a scene, a surrealistic
scene of the kind that I never imagined in
my life I would see. Which is, a thousand
mass murderers, or a thousand people there,
mostly men, a few women.
A thousand mass murderers and they were all
staring at us. They didn't look very happy.
We've later found out they weren't very happy.
And I thought to myself, "Look at these people."
And that we have to humanize them. They're
not a mass of people; they're an individual
mass murderer, a thousand times over, who
individually and collectively decided to work
in concert to slaughter their victims. We
need to humanize them. And part of that is
recognizing that, as other human beings have
done -- they can make decisions based on their
values to slaughter people.
[Daniel coughs]
Listen to Anne, a Tutsi survivor, captured,
hiding in the bush as Hutu used dogs to ferret
every last Tutsi out. She, I'm, she say that,
"They slashed my right arm. Then while they
were," thank you. I've reached that age. "Then
while, she had to watch as a Hutu killed all
my children in front of me and they slashed
my right arm. Then," and these are her words,
"while they were raping me, they were saying
that they wanted to kill all Tutsis."
This is what the perpetrators were saying.
They wanted to do it. So then in the future,
all that would be left would be drawings to
show that there were once a people called
Tutsi. And why do the Hutu want to obliterate
the Tutsis? So they wanted to, but why did
they want to do it? Ellie Nicarambe, whom
you've seen, explains that the killers did
not know that the Tutsi were human beings,
because if they had thought about that, they
wouldn't have killed them.
"Let me also include myself." He says this
about himself as well. "Let me also include
myself as someone who accepted it. I wouldn't
have accepted that the Tutsi are human beings."
He's emphatic about this being the common
view and common knowledge among all Hutu.
"As I was hearing it," he explains, "I had
the same perception as others at the time."
Adding, that is was such a fact of Hutu society,
that no Hutu, and these are his words, "Could
swear and lie to you that he did not know
that." What's the effect of such views? So
they wanna do it, they wanna do it because
they have these views. What's the effect of
the views upon the killers? And Nicarmbe explains,
"It is a cloud that came into people's hearts
and covered them and everything became dark.
Because to see someone standing in front of
you without any energy, and you hold your
machete on, your machete high, or a club and
hit him, it is something difficult that was
done with a lot of anger and rage. I mean,
this genocide."
The perpetrators of genocide overwhelmingly
are willful killers believing what they're;
that what they're doing is right and necessary.
How they came to do it, or how they're gonna
do it in different instances of genocide is
more complicated, and it varies from case
to case.
And what they actually believe varies quite
a lot, but this is the core of it. One of
the things I focus on in the film and in the
book as well is the cruelty of the perpetrators,
which is almost always left out of the analysis.
The cruelty is almost endemic, almost, not,
not entirely to mass murder and genocide.
Why are the perpetrators so unnecessarily
cruel to their victims? Torturing them, beating
them, degrading them in ways that are not
necessary for the simple act of killing.
The truth is that we need to em-, to humanize
not just the perpetrators, but also the victims.
Now, this may surprise you because we all
empathize with the victims. When we think
about them, we can have some sense, some sense,
of the suffering and the horror that they
endured.
But we need to humanize them because we lose
their individuality in the numbers. A thousand
people are, the perpetrators kill a thousand
people here, 400 thousand there, millions
here; it's easy to lose the individuality
of each of the victims. I have sat across,
stood across, walked with victims from genocides
arou--
[Daniel coughs and clears throat]
Excuse me.
[Daniel coughs]
from genocides or mass eliminations around
the world. You hear their stories, you see
their suffering; these are the ones who ar-,
who survived. They are marked, indelibly,
with horror and suffering for their whole
lives. We need to do it. And the reason we
need to do it is because it is focusing on
what they are going through, and imagining
what it would be like for any of us or our
family members to go through it, which will
motivate us and motivate our political leaders
if we can get them to start thinking this
way, to do something to stop it or prevent
it. So, we need to humanize the victims because
it's the right thing to do and because it's
the politically important thing to do.
We need to tell the truth about what starts
genocides.
[Daniel coughs]
It's not ethnic con-, it's not ethnic conflict.
It's not hatred spun out of control. It's
not all of the structural or transhistorical
factors that are often said to start genocides.
All these things may go in to creating the
conditions under which they begin, but ultimately,
almost every genocide has begun because one
person or small group of people have made
a decision to slaughter or otherwise eliminate
the victims.
[Daniel coughs]
We can name these people. We often know when
the decision was taken.
[Daniel clear throat]
Excuse me. All the things that are necessary
for genocides to occur, such as a willing
population of perpetrators who will carry
out the orders and they have found them, but
if this decision is not taken, if Hitler or
Pol Pot or Bagosora or Milosevic or al-Bashir,
decided not to initiate mass slaughter, eliminationism
or genocide, it would not happen. And they
could've always, in every instance, decided
to do otherwise.
This is critically important to recognize
because when you shift the discussion away
from this abstraction, such as ethnic conflict
or transhistorical forces or globalization
or capitalism, or whatever you want to say,
and you start focusing on the human beings
who actually make the decisions, you can begin
to think very differently about policy responses.
And how to make other leaders, the future
or would-be genocidal leaders make other decisions
in the future.
[Daniel clears throat]
And this brings us back to the problem of
politics. It begins because political leaders
have political goals of social transformation,
of dominance, power, of creating a utopia
as they understand it, of gaining or maintaining
territory, or what have you.
It's politics and we need to reinsert or recapture
genocide eliminationism into our understanding
of politics, which is has been sequestered
from. It's treated as something that sort
of out of this world. It's another form of
politics; a politics of eliminationism, which
is on a continuum with other kinds of repressive
and even normal politics. It's politics, which
we can meet with politics.
We must tell the truth about what we do, which
is next to nothing.
[Daniel clears throat]
Really, next to nothing. We stand by and watch
as people get slaughtered, expelled, raped,
otherwise brutalized. And we need to tell
the truth about why we do nothing because
of cynicism of our political leaders, which
are, who are governed by the hallowed creation
of national interest. That is, we only do
something that is within our nation's interests,
however that is defined. And our political
leaders will speak fine words about how they
care and about how they would like to stop
it, in fact, in the future, will stop such
things and prevent them, but they don't. And
they give all kinds of excuses for why they
don't do sometimes, don't take sometimes a
very simple and local cause actions that would
save the lives of enormous numbers of people.
But it's not just our political leaders' cynicism
and the creative national interest; it's also
the international community. Which, contrary
to how it's typically pro-, portrayed, is
actually set up to do nothing. The international
community is located centrally in the body
of the United Nations, which has as its bedrock
principle, state sovereignty and the respect
and protection of state sovereignty. Which
means, well, which means that when leaders
start killing their people, it's almost guaranteed
that nothing will be done.
Because if you're going to forcefully intervene
in another country where political, where
state, or the, is slaughtering its own people,
you need to abridge their sovereignty, according
to international law, because they haven't
attacked you, it is aggressive war. You are
actually committing a transgression internationally.
What the International Committee says to leaders
is, "If you cross someone's borders and start
killing people, we will come after you. You're
fair game; it's war. But as long as you slaughter
and expel, incarcerate, rape or do whatever
you do to people in your own country, we will
say you're a very bad person and maybe an
international court will one day call you
in to account, but really there's nothing
we're going to do." That's what the international
system says.
We need to tell the truth about what is wrong,
and it's really very simple to characterize
what is wrong. The world, with its collective
strength, which is composed mainly of countries
and particularly, if you look at the economically
and politically powerful countries of the
world, those of the West, mainly composed
of countries that abhor mass slaughter and
eliminationism.
And the world with its collective strength
led by the United States and Western powers
with their enormous strength, look upon these
weak and poor countries and the governments
that, and the leaders that rule them, slaughtering
their people, and they do nothing. And if
you were a naive person, you would say, "How
can this be? This doesn't make sense."
But this is the situation in the world. That's
what's wrong and we need to tell the truth
about how it can be changed and about what
can be done. And the truth is -- everything.
And when I say everything, I mean everything
or pretty close to everything.
[Daniel coughs]
I think it would be pretty easy to stop most
of the mass killing in the world if we had
a little political wor-, will and were willing
to do to take a few basic steps to change
the international context for genocidal, or
would-be genocidal leaders. If I'm right that
it's politics, it's not just a volca-, a human
volcanic eruption, and if I'm right, then
one leader or a small group of people make
the decision, and that they do so when they
calculate the cost and benefits of what they're
doing.
After all, these are political leaders who
know how to calculate costs and benefits.
Even those who are besotted by ideologies,
who truly believe that go-that the people
they're targeting are vermin, no matter how
besotted they are by ideologies, these are
people who have risen to the pinnacle of power
in their countries, which people don't do
if they're not cool, calculating practitioners
of cost and advantage and of power.
If it's politics and started by a small group
of people, one person who calculates cost
and benefits, that means we can respond politically
by designing an international context and
a set of responses that would change their
cost/benefit calculus. And we'll get them
to see that the cost of initiating elimination
assaults against the people they would otherwise
target are too great, and so they'll say to
themselves, "You know, I have to find a different
way to deal with this problem." As they understand
the problem. So, how do we do this? I will
just be very brief.
To have an international anti-eliminationist
system, you would need three components. An
intervention system, so when they begin, you
can do something to stop it. A justice or
punishment system, so that you can punish
the people afterward -- bring them to justice.
And a prevention system to try to prevent
them from beginning in the first place. Now,
to the extent that there is serious, that
there are measures being taken today, it's
in the world of justice.
There's an international criminal court, but
it is too limited, too slow, too late to be
a one stop shopping response to the problem
of mass murder and eliminationism. There are
talk, there is talk about rapid deployment
forces at the UN and other forms of intervention
through the UN; there's talk of it. But where
we should really be placing our emphasis is
on prevention for the obvious reason that
we don't want these things to begin in the
first place. Keep in mind that in a day, the
perpetrators can kill ten thousand people.
We don't want them to begin for another reason,
which is they're much harder to stop, or prevent
that is, they're much harder to stop before
they begin than to stop once they are underway.
Because then you're, you have the problem
of having to intervene militarily, perhaps.
And what do you do with the perpetrators?
How do you get them to stop when they've already
thrown their lot in with this kind of policy?
And so, and another reason we should focus
on prevention is prevention, a preventive
system can target every would-be, if it's
a system, every would-be perpetrator that
is a political leader so, which means you
don't have to know where they're about to
begin.
You don't have to wait till they begin to
begin to do something. Just as laws in our
country and the police forces, which guarantee
them, I fe-, preemptively, prevent an enormous
amount of crime that would otherwise take
place. They fail, there still is crime. Because
everyone knows that if you break the law,
the punishment can, or may, or in some cases,
almost certainly will ensue. You need an international
preventive system that would operate the same
way so we don't have to be able to figure
out where the next genocide is going to happen
and then bring measures to bear on the would
be perpetrators.
[Daniel clears throat]
Unfortunately, to do this, you need to be
willing to use force, and you have to guarantee
that you're going to use it.
And things you have to, and the, the thing
you have to make clear is that if a genocidal
leaders begin to slaughter their people, that
you, the United States, NATO, will use their
military forces as they did in Bosnia to degrade
the militaries of these, of the states that
undertake the perpetration of genocide. Target
military facilities, munitions, forces, stay
away from civilian infrastructure; no dictator
wants his military to be destroyed.
The leaders of these militaries don't want
their capacities to be destroyed. In Bosnia,
when we finally began to bomb seriously, we
being NATO, in 1995, after the massacre in
Srebrenica, Milosevic came to the negotiation
table in three weeks, and it was over. If
we had bombed three years earlier when it
began, the slaughter would have never taken
place. I asked the President of Bosnia, in
Herzigo- Herzegovina, Izetbegovic, what would
have happened if we had bombed in 1992, he
said it would have changed everything. It
would've never happened. If you bomb, and
you make it clear you're going to do it again,
many would-be killers would think twice about
starting.
If you're willing to target the killers, themselves,
that is, the leaders of the countries, you'll
have a doubly effective means of preventing
them from doing what they do. Any genocidal
leader and those serving in high-level positions
should know that if they b-, undertake a genocidal
campaign against a group of people that they
will have bounties placed on their heads of
sizable amount so that they know they can
never go to sleep sure that they will wake
up the next day. Now, the two questions about
such a pre-, such a thing: would it be effective,
and are we comfortable, or is it right to
do?
[audience member coughs]
I asked the President of Bosnia, who knew
Milosevic very, very well, would Milosevic
ever have begun the genocide against the Bosnians
had there been a bounty system in place? And
he said to me, "I don't think he would have."
This is in the film. I asked Tharcisse Karugarama,
the Justice Minister of Rwanda, who has steeped
himself in the problem of genocide as much
as any other public figure of our time, processing
1.2 million people suspected of having participated
in the genocide; convicting about 900 thousand
of them. I asked him, "Would a bounty system
have prevented the Rwandan genocide?" And
he said, "Definitely, definitely, definitely,
definitely, many times definitely." And he
explained--
[Daniel clears throat]
"If people knew that at the end of the day
they'll be the losers, they never invest in
a losing enterprise because genocide, as you
correctly pointed out, is a political enterprise.
It's a political game, but again, it's a power
play. It's wealth; it's everything. So if
people involved in it knew at the end of the
day they'd be the losers, they would not play
the game. That's for sure."
Now we need to tell the truth, and I'll get
back to the advisability of such a notion
in a moment, we need to tell the truth about
the impossibility or futility of putting into
genocide. If we had been here a hundred years
ago, and I had said at that time, that it
would be possible to put an end to imperialism,
to st-, to prevent war from being a principle
means by which many states in the world relate
to one another, and that human rights and
political rights would be respected in many,
many, many countries around the world, there'd
be such powerful public norm that even those
countries that don't respect them pay lip
service to them, you would've thought I was
mad.
Imperialism, the most powerful countries in
the world were the imperialist powers. It
was endemic to humankind. The world was carved
up by the imperialists. Who could foresee
the, that imperialism, at a large scale, would
come to an end quite rapidly, and today is
not a problem in the world, except for in
very local areas. War was considered to be
a natural state of humankind, or states. Peace
was often conceived of as being but the interlude
between war.
And again, many of the major powers of the
world were, who, were engaged and would be
engaged in major wars against one another.
The idea that it would cease to be a means
by which many states in the world relate to
each other would not have been believed at
the time. And human rights and political rights,
and people might have said, "Well, maybe in
England. Maybe in the United States, but not
in the rest of the world where they were in
embryonic form at best, in most places." And
yet they are. Eliminating eliminationism,
putting an end to it is much easier than putting
an end to these analogous, or related, international
and national violations.
In part, because these other achievements
have already been made. And also, because
if my analysis is correct and it really is
a few people who make the decisions to slaughter
so many -- of course they need the others
to carry them out -- but without the initiation,
the perpetrator on the ground would never
ever start slaughtering people in their en-,
all over the country. If that is correct,
what follows from it is that it only takes
a few other leaders, a few moral men and women,
the President of the United States, the leaders
of some European countries and elsewhere,
to make a decision to change the international
system and change the cost/benefit calculus
or the sy-, the cost/benefit incentives that
would-be genocidal leaders phase.
It really could be done that easily. Now we
have to tell the truth about what's radical.
And this gets back to the advisability of
the boundaries, but there are other things
to do as well. The critical think to keep
in mind is how do we change the cost/benefit
calculus? Lots of things are possible. I gave
you two very powerful ones.
About the advisability, the truth is that
what I'm proposing, although maybe people,
or some people think of it as radical, is
not radical at all. What is radical, indeed,
there is nothing more radical than the status
quo. The status quo is what's radical because
the status quo is people, leaders and those
who serve them start slaughtering people,
men, women, children, brutalizing them, expelling
them, destroying their lives, raping women
systematically, and we stand by and let it
happen by the hundreds of thousands of millions.
That is radical. Putting a bounty on the head
of a per-, someone who would do this, to prevent
him from doing it, that's not radical. That's
nothing. You should know that the US has a
bounty program. Our country has a bounty program.
It's been around for a few decades, overseen
by both democratic and republican presidents
and administrations. President Obama currently
oversees it, and it's, but it's for terrorists.
It's for the capture of terrorists.
[audience member coughs]
So we have a bounty program that says, "If
you slaughter a few Americans, we'll put huge
sums of money on your head, yet if you kill
people of another country by the hundreds
of thousands, we will do nothing." All we
need to do is extend a program that's already
in place, that's been operating and has been
quite effective. And we can start saving lives.
So, finally we have to tell the truth about
our duty, and it concerns protecting innocent
people. Ask yourselves the following question,"
What if this were April 1994 today, and the
Rwanda genocide were about to begin? Today.
A genocide which took the lives of 800 thousand
people and destroyed and many other and in
so many ways the lives of others who survived."
And you knew you had a choice. They're gonna
do it, unless you have a bounty program, or
unless you're willing to take military measures.
What would you choose? To put a bounty on
the heads, prospectively, of the Rwandan leaders
and save the lives of hundreds of thousands
of people, or to say, "No, we shouldn't do
that," and let the Rwandan genocide occur?
That is the question we really have to ask
ourselves, and in doing so, consult your hearts
and your minds and as-, think about what your
duty is, what the duty of the President of
the United States is. To save lives. Thank
you.
[applause]
>>presenter: Thank you, Daniel, for that,
is this on? Great. Thank you for that fascinating
and frankly pretty chilling description of,
of where we're at with this. I wanna open
up the floor for questions, but I'll start
it off really quickly, myself. There's also
a cost/benefit analysis that our political
leaders are making in our country, and the
international community is making its and
its operations about the cost and benefits
of intervening in this space. Can you talk
a little bit about how we can tilt the equation
in those cases as well?
>>Daniel: Look, our leaders, including President
Obama, who's been enormously disappointing,
he's done nothing in Sudan, and our political
leaders basically stand by time and time again.
The only way to get them to move is to put
political pressure on them. And to make it
clear that the old excuses will not fly; that
we can't do anything, that's beyond our control,
there's just those people over there doing
it. And that if our President, our Secretary
of State and others stands by and does nothing,
that they will be held morally culpable, that
there is a price, a moral price or price of
reputation for them to pay. Put pressure on
them.
And this, so we need to change the discourse
from being, "Oh my God, look what's going
on in Sudan, isn't it horrible," to, "Why
are the people in Washington doing nothing?"
And what is their responsibility and what
kind of blood is on their hands? We can do
it with technology, we can do it with grass
roots organization, we can make a, get a different
conversation going.
A different discourse about who is responsible
and what they must do and what the political
and human consequences are of their failures.
Similarly, we should put the leaders of other
countries, presidents, prime ministers, whatever
they call themselves, cabinet level leader,
leaders of military and police, they should
all be put on notice. We have technology;
it can help us do it. Of what will happen
to them if they start killing people in their
own country or otherwise eliminating them.
And what has happened in the cases that the
people have been prosecuted, those have been
prosecuted. Put 'em on notice, and they're
not on notice right now. They may have some
vague notions. They may think, "Well, it's
not my problem. I'm just following orders.
Or, or it's the political leaders making the
decision."
But they should all be told. We have the means
to do it now and no one's doing it. And so
we should think about how we, and you here,
have great capacity to do this, can get a
new international conversation and notification
system in place so that we don't just all
end up surprised again when the next one happens
and then it goes on and on and on.
>>presenter: Other questions?
[pause]
>>male audience member 1: Hi. Thanks, it's
actually two questions. First question is
-- how did you get interested in the subject?
If you have maybe in your history been touched
by this in some personal way. And the second
question is we sort of all agree r-, r-, Rwanda
was a genocide and right now, several others,
conflicts, there's no questions about it,
but I kinda wanna know what you're, how you
see the issue with the Palestinians, is that
a war or is it a eliminationist policy, as
you put it? And if it's a war, then is the
United Nations failing to prevent something?
It was chartered to do that alone, what you
said, it should be also doing which you present,
preventing genocides.
>>Daniel: Ok. If we, to the first question,
if we had run the film for another minute,
you would've had your answer to the part of
the answer to the first question. My father's
a survivor of the Holocaust and he, he was,
he was and he's still around. He's a professor,
and this was his field of study, so I grew
up s-, with this material around my home and,
indeed, we lived in Germany when I was a child.
When I was ten, he was doing research the
subject and so I've been thinking about this
material, or this subject, for as long as
I can remember thinking about serious things.
So, that's how I first became interested.
I mean, th-, that's the kind of biographical
reason, there are also the intellectual reasons
to many children of survivors of many genocides
who don't end up studying this professionally.
I wrote about the Holocaust at, I wr-, as
Steve said at first because I didn't think,
I knew that perpetrators hadn't been studied.
There was a gaping hole in our knowledge,
so you understand why the people actually,
who they are and why they do it, you can't
explain why it happens. And once I started
that, I then continued working in this area
and wrote the book, Worse than War, and did
the film because I thought that, if what I'm
telling you is true, and I certainly believe
it is, that much of what has been said about
genocide has been partial or wrong. And that
if we rethink and re-, and if we rethink what
we-the, the problem, the nature of the problem,
then we can actually do a great deal; not
just understand it better, but to save people's
lives. So, that's how, that's the, those are
the intellectual and moral reasons for doing
it.
With regard to the Middle East conflict, or
the Palestine-Israeli conflict, whatever you,
whatever term you wanna use, it's not genocide
and I don't think it's an elimination assault.
I presume you meant by the Israelis upon the
Palestinians. And it, this is a hornets' nest
of a, of, of a conflict, and it's a hornets'
nest of a discussion often as well and I don't
really wanna enter in, enter into it full-
blown right now. There is a, there a terrible
conflict over land and security and, and,
and self-governance and many other things
in which two people are intermeshed.
There are, they, the majority of Israelis
and Israeli leadership haven't, are not, have
no intention or desire to eliminate the Palestinian
people. And they're not undertaking eliminationist
policies as such, even if you could, you might
want to make an argument that on the margins,
say, "All right, and then we won't have to
talk about it." What should be said, is that
in 1948, there were eliminationist, there,
there were eliminationist assaults on both
sides, but the Israelis did as well to clear
the land at that time of Palestinians so that
the Israel that emerged would be more governable
from their perspective. So, there is that
original sin, certainly, in the founding of
the state of Israel, and we should be clear
about that.
>>male audience member 2: Hi, thanks. I mean,
I think we're all in agreement about being,
about finding ways to find problems, about
finding ways to stop genocide and, but one
question I have is you talk about having like,
a morally, a moral, it almost sounds like
a moral leader who's making these judgments,
and we see from just different, varying opinions
that one morality can't make a rule for everyone.
For example, a lot of what can be done for
people we want to condemn on genocide can
also be put on our leadership's head. And
how do we then answer questions like that,
especially during Bush's regime when lots
of people were dying and the entire international
world was, was talking to us, sorry--
>>Daniel: Sure.
>>male audience member 2: I lost my question,
but I, but, sorry.
>>Daniel: That's ok. Look, there are two kinds
of answers to that. One is to, to say that,
this is, this is the human condition. We have
to, we have to talk it out, make your arguments,
make them persuasive, and if you have a more
persuasive argument than I do and convince
more people then I can, well then you're gonna
have more people with your point of view on
the thing yours or whoev-, whatever, whoever
the "you" are, or whatever the point of view
is than mine.
We're in the situation where we have, where
people are dying, sometimes by American military
accor-, because of American military forces.
But what I've been talking about is dying
because people are setting out to slaughter
populations. And we do our best to try to
make sense of it and to persuade people to
agree and for political leaders to enact policies
to do something about it. So, that's one thing.
It just, it, being silent is b-, not talking
about it and not trying to figure out how
best to do it is not the solution. It's a
totally losing proposition cause we'll be
where we are right now.
The, so, the second thing is that whatever
we can agree upon, we can agree upon one thing,
which is slaughtering children should not
happen. Or we can take the very easy cases.
Rwanda is a very easy case. That's why I put
it forward. We, you and I, may not agree,
I'm, I'm not presuming any views on your part.
You and me may not agree about whether situation
X would fall into the eliminationist category,
or whether we should do something about it.
At, so let's not agree upon that.
But let's do what we can do on the cases that
we can agree about. If we stop one genocide
or one mass elimination, we've saved so many
lives, and we've saved so many lives from
being ruined.
[audience member coughs]
And so, even if we can't agree on many others
and we fail on some, let's do it right one
time. If s-, if you're, if the political authorities
in New York, the police authority, the police,
were to figure out a way to reduce the murder
rate in New York by half in a year, we would
be singing "Hallelujah! How did they do it?"
And it would be a tremendous thing. It would
save a few hundred lives; I don't know the
exact figures. And we would try to replicate
what they did in c-, city after city. If we
stop one genocide, it's a thousand times,
maybe more than a thousand times, more productive
in the life, in the saving of lives. So, all,
all this on the margins there'll be disagreements.
Is this real eliminationism? Is this genocidal?
Do we want to enact a policy in this case?
That's always the case. Let's do the easy
cases. Let's do it one time. And let's do
it right.
And if we do it one time, it'll be a signal,
it'll be a signal and a lesson for the next
would be genocidal leader. That's why I think
it would be really easy if we prevent or stop
genocides, it will be produced, us, if we
make it serious that this is not just an isolated
event, it will produce a virtuous cycle in
which each will learn it will be, they'll
learn the lessons and they'll start looking
to solve their political problems in other
ways.
>>presenter: Almost out of time. Any more,
one more question?
>>male audience member 3: Hi, thanks for speaking
today. I have a two-part question that I think
my answers are what you just said, and if
so, that's fine. One is -- how do we know?
And the second one is -- how do we get agreement
to act? So, how do we know is, when a state
is controlling media, controlling access,
when do we know that we have good data, and
then the second is for, among especially among
nations, how do we get agreement to take that
action? Our recent case being the ship sunk
in South Korea. We, the US is basically doing
nothing and it looks like they will do nothing
cause there, we can't get agreement on that
-- political agreement. How do we get around
those?
>>Daniel: Look, the, the UN is, for this matter,
a pretty hopeless organization. And I say
this not as a republican who hates the UN
or as one who wants to celebrate American
power; I say this as a liberal internationalist.
It's just a hopeless organization for this
kind of matter.
It does a lot of good in other ways; the World
Health Organization, and many other things
they do good, but it's an en-, it actually
enables elimination assaults more than it
impedes them. And so we have to look to outside
the UN. On the question of knowing, we almost
always know at this point.
There's so much information available and,
and, and YouTube itself, YouTube itself, is
now instrumental for getting information out,
from people loading stuff up from their phones
and, and, and other means. We know very quickly.
Refugee streams begin. We have satellite photography;
we have local reports now. We know almost
immediately. Knowledge is not a problem, by
and large. And as I said earlier, maybe there's
some cases where it is, but, but let's deal
with those cases where we get information.
Now what happened, what, what should happen
is there should be an international watchdog
agency created through treaty.
One country can set it up. We're, NATO can
set it up. Staffed by experts, impartial experts,
who will be charged with receiving information,
everybody follows information, and they have
the duty, if there's report of an eliminationist
assault, to render a quick finding in a matter
of days about whether it's taking place. Or
whether the, there's probable cause, it's,
is, the suspicion is strong enough that it's
taking place. If they say so, the countries
that are, the country that is, that is suspected
of undertaking a genocidal or eliminationist
assault would have to then take a series of,
do a series of things, including letting international
observers -- if necessary military force -- open
the country up, stop everything they're doing
immediately. And if not, then a whole series
of sanctions and measures get triggered.
Now, this has to be done outside the UN because
you'll never get agreement because of the
security council and its constitution and,
and there have been actions taken outside
of this, outside the UN, outside of, not under
UN auspices, and sometimes international wars
cry foul, but who, who can say that it wasn't
right to end the Bosnian genocide with NATO
bombing? NATO could just set this up. And
some people might say that this is not kosher
and so on, ok, let them say it. And they can
be on the side of saying, "Well, we'll do
nothing." And we can be on the side of saying
we're gonna save lives.
So create a dedicated organization with expertise
and a set of, a set of triggers that will,
and, which will then unleash a series of clearly
articulated measures that'll be known ahead
of time to everybody. And act upon it. We
can change the world -- at least in this one
critical respect.
Thank you, everyone.
[applause]